pour le commun des mortels une vache
laitière ça va au pâturage pourtant ce
mode d'élevage est en très nette perte
de vitesse ont un peu partout dans le
monde sauf dans de rares pays comme la
suède
une vache à qui on fait miroiter des
champs verdoyants à l'aide d'un casque
de réalité virtuelle une expérience du
ministère russe de l'agriculture en 2019
[Musique]
un producteur laitier turc qui reprend
l'expérience pour améliorer le quotidien
de ses vaches
de nos jours près de 90 % des bovins
laitiers des pays industrialisés ne vont
jamais au pâturage
comme chez jack rodenberg en ontario cet
ex producteur laitier qui est
aujourd'hui consultant dans le milieu ne
jure que par la stabulation libre
on essaie vraiment de donner à la vache
le plus confort possible je crois
qu'elle est beaucoup plus à l'aise en
liberté dans une étable moderne qu'elle
peut l'être au pâturage
en 2014 jack cronenberg et d'autres
producteurs laitiers ont visité des
fermes en suède c'est l'un des seuls
pays au monde où le pâturage est
obligatoire pour tous les troupeaux
qu'ils soient biologiques ou
conventionnelle dans ce pays la sortie
des vaches au printemps est une
véritable fête populaire et citoyen se
pressent aux portes des étables pour
assister à ce qu'on appelle coup slap un
mot suédois qui veut dire relâchement
des vaches
[Musique]
vous voulez apprendre de cette
expérience les consommateurs suédois
sont très sensibles aux pratiques de
l'industrie
on a voulu comprendre comment les
producteurs jongler avec cela et ont
tiré des leçons
en suède le pâturage est obligatoire
depuis 1988 cette année là le
gouvernement a adopté une loi dont le
but était de permettre aux animaux
d'élevage d'exprimer leur comportement
naturel
[Musique]
faut voir ce qu'est réellement bien être
animal
les bêtes ont évolué vers la
domestication sur des milliers d'années
une première vague vivait au pâturage et
dans de grands espaces
leur physiologie leurs comportements
sont adaptés à ces conditions de travail
peuvent qu'une des choses
[Musique]
helen johansson est à la tête d'une des
plus grosses fermes laitières de la
suède ammann stade dont sud ouest du
pays elle élève ses trois cent cinquante
vaches en stabulation libre dans sa
région la loire au caire que ces animaux
aille au pâturage quatre mois par année
beau temps mauvais temps
l'été les portes sont ouvertes jour
inutiq l'automne nous les ouvrons
seulement le jour
[Musique]
c'est bien de voir les vaches et
l'extérieur regardez les elles sont
belles à voir elles sont heureuses
étendu sur le gazon
so what vers elles sont les avantages du
pâturage au fond du gouffre c'est bon
pour les sabots les muscles et la santé
mentale des vaches
like to buy side à l'extérieur elles
interagissent différemment et le coût
réel joue entre elles
plusieurs études scientifiques
démontrent que 62% des vaches vont au
pâturage lorsqu'elles ont chois de plus
celle qui broutent régulièrement dans
les champs ont moins de problèmes de
boiterie de lésions au jarret et de
mammites que celles qui sont élevées en
stabulation libre ou entravés
mais ces bénéfices se font au détriment
du rendement l'est pendant la saison du
pâturage
nous perdons 10 % de revenus parce
qu'elles produisent moins de lait à
l'extérieur les vaches mangent moins et
leur alimentation est moins équilibré à
l'intérieur elle suivre une diète bien
précises on leur donne des protéines et
des grains une vache vous savez c'est un
peu comme une athlète olympique si elle
se nourrit mal ces résultats seront
vraiment moins
seule la dodgers le bien-être animal
c'est plus que des vaches qui vont au
pâturage
fireworks rome est à la tête de la
fédération des fermiers suédois son
organisation réclame depuis plusieurs
années l'abolition du pâturage
obligatoires we want more flex nous
voulons plus de flexibilité pour les
éleveurs ils doivent pouvoir décider eux
mêmes qu'en sortir livre h et quand
l'iran tries to one au score
il faut dire que cette loi a été adopté
alors que la moyenne des fermes suédoise
comptait 18 vaches tout élevé en
stabulation entravée
aujourd'hui les fermes du pays comptent
en moyenne 100 de vache en majorité en
stabulation libre
je crois que cette exigence biais du
fait qu'on devait compenser les longs
mois d'hiver passé dans de vieilles
granges mal adapté par du pâturage l'été
[Musique]
mais de nos jours les étapes qu'on
construit son confortable à longueur
d'année
[Musique]
tous les sondages montrent qu aux yeux
des consommateurs suédois de pâturage
obligatoire est très important que
3 des français ce qui était différent il
ya 40 ans quand la loi a été adoptée
à l'époque la suède n'était pas membre
de l'union européenne et la situation
économique était différent nous voulions
promouvoir nos valeurs en matière de
bien-être animal
les choses ont changé car maintenant nos
produits rivalisent avec les
importations la situation est plus
difficile pour les producteurs laitiers
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était en 1988
helen johansson elle voudrait être
compensé par l'état pour les pertes
encourues par le recours aux pâturages
l'été mais malgré tout si la loi était
assouplie son choix seraient claires je
les mettrai tout d'or enfin peut-être
pas tout mais c'est bon pour elle
[Musique]
le voyage ensuite de jack rodenberg ne
l'a pas convaincu les baisses de
rendement attribuable aux pâturages le
conforte dans son affection pour le
modèle de stabulation libre
c'est les consommateurs comprennent nos
façons de faire nous avons bon espoir
qu'ils comprendront que les vaches ont
confortable dans nos étables et que ce
n'est pas nécessaire de les envoyer au
pâturage pour qu'ils aient une vie
agréable
[Musique]
pour l'instant le recours au pâturage
est plutôt rare au canada seuls les
producteurs biologiques sont obligés
d'envoyer leurs vaches brouter de
l'herbe en été marc et pierre gosselin à
saint jean sur richelieu et l'une
d'elles en production biologique la
prémisse de base c'est de dire mais on
veut pouvoir après aux vaches un
environnement le plus proche au titre de
leur marque à la basse les vaches c'est
un humain c'est fait pour goûter à
l'extérieur pour interagir ou par tirage
pour manger de l'herbe au moins un peu
contre nature de les confiner constat
main
la productrice a adopté un système qui
lui permet d'offrir une herbe de qualité
à ses vaches contrairement à ce qui se
fait en suède où les parcelles sont
laissés en friche son chant est
subdivisé en bande l et envoie paître
ses animaux en rotation ici la baisse de
rendement allait occasionner par le
pâturage récompensés autrement
certaines questions regard de notre
production laitière par litre par jour
par vache on est inférieure à la moyenne
mais moi je considère que c'est plus
rentable parce que pendant cinq mois
j'ai pas besoin de calculer d'abord donc
de posséder des infrastructures pour
loger des aliments pour nous c'est loin
d'entreposage pour le foin sec aussi
quand on regarde les vaches au pâturage
ils sont en train d'étendre le fumier de
se nourrir elle même donc une façon
d'éliminer des coûts c'est aussi du
travail qui est libéré quand les vaches
sont pas fait rage et s'occupe
d'elle-même
chaque année elle immortalise la
première sortie des vaches au printemps
un mini-coup slave québécois
on voit visuellement que les vaches à
temps d'aller d'or et les aime se
passait toujours un spectacle vraiment
drôle j'ai vraiment gré à mon cinquième
c'est le décor finma
seul un an et demi pour cent des
producteurs laitiers du canada ont
l'obligation d'envoyer leurs vaches au
pâturage parce qu'ils produisent du lait
biologique la pratique pourrait
toutefois se répandre les experts qui
guide les producteurs laitiers du pays
recommande maintenant de laisser les
vaches bougies le plus souvent possible
en les logeant en stabulation libre ou
en les envoyant au pâturage au grand
bonheur de certains consommateurs je
n'ai pas d'idée oglou à quelques années
je pense à deux voix des verts dans la
pâture dans les prés pas du tout pas une
c'est bon plus haut niveau il est en
liberté [ __ ] d'aller le preppy
d'honorer pour marcher j'ai eu un
reportage justement pour sa semaine
verte que
la diva était de libre ils vivent a pu
bien que ces deux ans fermé